this is the strongest Marine in one
piece of all time and it's someone no
one would have expected what about the
Admirals except for the yonko they can
easily defeat every other pirate in the
world with their crazily overpowered
devil fruits aokiji can freeze entire
oceans kizaru can attack with the speed
of light fujitora can summon giant
meteors and green ball is an entire
deadly Forest but as you've probably
guessed it's none of the Admirals no one
is that Luffy's grandfather GARP or the
former Fleet Admiral sengoku two of the
strongest Marines ever famous for their
legendary battles with the likes of
Whitebeard Roger or Roxy zabek and it's
not even the current Fleet Admiral akinu
Luffy's biggest enemy next to Blackbeard
his lava powers make him the strongest
Marine we've seen fight in one piece so
far however there is one mysterious
character that could be even more
powerful than any other Marine he only
answers to the gorosei directly and is
one of the most badass and battle
scarred looking Marines we've ever seen
the world government
commander-in-chief Kong subscribe